i want to go to a
quick little segment here um
this is something that's come up quite a
few times with
my friends and family it's come up over
and over in the emails
it's come up on the youtube chats
and then this um
netflix documentary came out and
everyone went abuzz
and so i want to talk about tech
boundaries with your kids
i want to talk about this wackadoo
season that we are in
we are amidst one of the greatest social
experiments
of all time we're almost
overnight and i'm talking about from
like 2010 to 2019
we started putting everything up online
we started spending
lots and lots of hours playing video
games we started putting everything on
facebook all of our family photos all of
our friends all the things we love
all the things that we are interested in
and the tech companies started tracking
us
and listening to us and watching us and
then
watching how we behaved and how we
answered things and whether we loved
things or didn't love things and liked
things and
then all of a sudden 2020 hit and
everyone went home
and what little privacy left but little
human interaction left between a teacher
and a student
between a college professor and their
grad student
all of that went online
but hard conversations between a boss
and an employee
that went online we're doing everything
virtually now
and so we have taken all of our lives
and
dumped them into the internet
onto zoom onto facetime
onto all these platforms into these
laptops
we are doing a massive social experiment
we are putting everybody's
words and thoughts and dreams and hopes
and snapshots wouldn't our normal
developmental processes we're putting
them in black and white to be etched in
stone forever they're always going to be
there
and we don't know how this wraps up
right
if you haven't watched the social
dilemma watch it
it's intense and it will hopefully make
you rethink some things about the way
you engage with social media the way you
engage with the computers
but i want to talk about screen time
with kids screen time in your homes
i think tech can be it's got some great
uses it's got some
really extraordinary things that help us
see different pictures of our earth of
our world of relationships et cetera
but can also be dangerous and handing a
and i don't say dangerous in some
dramatic orwellian
dun dun dun kind of way what i mean is
kids or kids and we live in a world now
where folks are going back and mining
things that 14 year olds said
that 12 year olds said that 18 year olds
said the 25
year old said and we have this science
that say their brains aren't developed
and we have this science that says they
are not smart
and yet we are holding people
accountable they're putting things in
black and white that they can't take
back
their bullying is happening in a way
used to your neighborhood
bully said something to you and it went
in one ear and you got sad and you got
your heart broken and you got punched in
the stomach or whatever happened
and then it it was gone and you had a
group of friends and over time it heals
or it doesn't right it lodges itself in
you and you work it you work it out
now you just see it in black and white
and you read it over and over and over
according to some google analytics
pornography searches increased by
four thousand seven hundred percent when
children under the age of 18 are not in
school
instead of asking their buddy what such
and such such and such is
or asking their mom or dad they just
google it
and so kids are being raised some of
these hard questions
what's the meaning of life is god real i
don't know what this particular sex act
is instead of finding somebody to ask
they're just going to the computer and
they're getting to see it in real time
they're going to see a lot of violence
you're going to see a lot of
things that they may never have
experienced and some of that's good not
the violence part but sometimes seeing
that other people do christmas
differently than they do
other people sing and dance differently
than they do that's great stuff
but some of it can be negative and so
here's the thing i want parents to stop
for a minute we thought this was going
to be a few weeks to quote unquote
flatten the curve right and here we are
nine months later
i want you to step back and parents have
a hard conversation with themselves
with each other um if you're a single
parent i want you to get with a friend
and i want you all to
talk together about tech boundaries in
your house
and i'm not saying this to be an
alarmist i'm saying this this is what i
do in my own home
and this is a big deal to me for a
hundred different reasons we can talk
about later
but a couple of things i want to
recommend folks do
number one i want you to lead by example
moms and dads
single moms and single dads married
couples
i want you to lead by example put the
screens away and this is the pot talking
to the kettle here man during the
hurricanes during the
coveted kick-up during the some of the
election stuff man i'm finding myself
glued to it
even my astros made it back to the
championship series and i found myself
checking in on them
man we got to lead by example that means
we got to put our screens down and start
looking our kids in the eyes
number two if they are at school on zoom
all day
or if they go to school and their school
has a big
chromebook program where they just sit
in front of a computer all day
that goes into their overall screen time
count for the day
so if they're if they are in school by
zoom
then when school's out the screens are
off that is their time for the day
they don't need to then pick up the
phone and then pick up netflix and then
pick up video games that's their time
okay that means we're gonna have to get
soccer balls again that means we're
gonna have to get tennis balls and old
tires and sticks i don't care what it is
that means we're gonna have to go to a
neighborhood park with a mask on or
whatever it is in your community
wherever you are listening to this
but that means the screen time's up
because we're we're slowly
morphing our kids where they're spending
10 hours a day on a screen and we're
calling it different because one school
and one's counseling and one's
violin practice my son's doing his
violin via zoom right now
and then all of a sudden it's now i get
my tv time it's like no man you've got
your screens you've got your screens
number two i want you to have a family
meeting with your kids
and i want you just to be honest with
them and say we were not designed to
stare in front of a screen 12 hours a
day 10 hours a day eight hours a day
and so we're gonna have a cold turkey
cut starting
that's kind of funny cold turkey cuts
that was hilarious i didn't mean to do
that but we're gonna start
stopping this we're gonna put a period
at the end of these sentences we're
gonna quit spending so much time on the
screens
and then i want you to write a plan and
put in a common area i'll just tell you
in my house my kids get one or two
shows a week sometimes that's a movie
they get
by themselves me and my wife just wanna
have a date night sometimes that is
saturday morning cartoons
and they can watch a couple of whatever
episodes on disney plus or whatever it
is
um but we try to be pretty intentional
what that means is we gotta go play with
them
that means i gotta not just sit there
and scroll mindlessly through the astros
game and whatever election nonsense is
going on
i gotta go actually go play with my kids
and it's frustrating and it's tiring
and i never ever ever regret it
i want you to not let kids have phones
or tablets
or screens in their bedrooms don't do
that
people ask me all the time i know i'm a
little bit of a lunatic when it comes to
this stuff
my kids don't have phones they're not
gonna have phones i've drawn that line
i've worked with too many folks behind
closed doors about tech with tech stuff
i've got too many friends who have
worked in the tech industries
it's just a terrible idea if you dig
into it folks in the tech industries
don't let their kids have screens
they don't let their kids have phones in
their bedrooms because they know
and so i want to challenge you all i
know you're going to send me your cards
and letters and i can't believe it's
child abuse you don't give your kid a
phone
fine call on me i want you to replace
screen time and i say this over and over
and over again
replace screen time with human beings
that could be you
that could be play dates that could be
go to the part time that could be just
go for walk time i don't care what it is
i promise downstream it will help you
too and the last thing is this
i can't tell you how many times over the
years i've heard
my kid's addicted to his phone my 14
year old is addicted to his ipad my
six-year-old
is addicted to whatever screen whatever
tv show
bullcrap no 14 year olds addicted to a
screen that a parent hasn't handed them
no seven-year-old is addicted to an ipad
or an iphone
that a parent hasn't handed them you are
the boss
moms and dads and for single parents who
are working three jobs trying to figure
it out
this sucks i wish there was another way
to say this nicely this is awful
it sucks it's heavy and it's hard i get
that i
so get that you get home and you just
want to lay down it's exhausting
you get tears in your eyes just thinking
about it it's exhausting
i know but you're the boss
and if we gotta go get coloring books we
gotta go get
legos and blocks or whatever the thing
is i don't give your kid a shovel until
i dig a hole
i don't care what it is but you're in
charge of the screens
you're in charge of what they're doing
in their off time
i want to give every parent permission
to take those reins back
take them back think of your kids
overall screen time as a big picture
not just school and then violin
and then entertainment and then weekends
and then and then and then
we can do it and i am optimistic that
this thing rallies around that we all
realize
man after nine months of just
being captivated by screens and video
games and more stuff that we all go whoa
this wasn't life so i want to go to
jacob
jacob actually called in here jacob in
wisconsin
jacob wrote in and sent me a real nice
email we did a show a few weeks ago
about a husband who was addicted to
video games and jacob
wrote in and i just said hey i want to
talk to jacob
directly so jacob it's good to hear from
you brother how are you doing this
morning
i'm doing fantastic how about yourself
i'm doing good
so you sent me a uh an email
and so tell us about it tell us what you
sent
so i sent an email in uh after i heard
your show
talking about the husband who was
addicted to video games
and that really resonated with me in my
life because i
i lived it uh in my college years i
i was addicted to a video game and i
played it
way way more than was healthy so
wanted to uh to share my story
man so what advice would you give
somebody who loves somebody who's
addicted to video games or to a 22 year
old who's listening to this or
a 38 year old who's got two kids and
uses video games just to hide what would
you what would you tell them
so the advice to the uh to someone who
is living with
or you know of dating somebody or maybe
to somebody who's addicted to video
games
be willing to stand your ground be
willing to stand
firm and set a boundary around looking
back like i ultimately was given an
ultimatum
that it's either my fiance
or the video game and
that was the best ultimatum of my life
and you chose fiance right
oh god yeah okay good deal good deal
and sadly i can look back at that time
and say it was actually a difficult
choice for me
and i it's something that i'm ashamed to
admit but i feel like it's important
for people to hear and know that it
really can get to be that
much of a presence in your life because
it is addicting
it can be addicting what would you tell
the
38 year old who's stuck right now
there's a better way and the people that
you engage with online
they feel like you're friends and when
you're
you're playing the game they interact
with you like friends
but when push comes to show they're not
going to be at your table
when times get tough they're not going
to be there to help you
when life gets hard
and if you play the game to the point
that i did where i was i was planning
more than 40 hours a week
nobody else stays around because you
don't have the time to invest in the
real relationships
what's one one thing you would like one
tactile one thing you would tell
somebody you need to do this right now
what would that be
you've just got you've got to get
something else in your life
uh one of the things i did to help break
it was i
i started bicycling and i just i got out
and i spent
an hour a day just going and doing
something different something that would
help me direct my focus elsewhere
and so like i was just talking about
with parents and these tech boundaries
you were trying to get off of video
games and so you chose another behavior
which was riding bikes outside for an
hour
did that end up healing other parts of
your life too
oh yeah i mean it made a huge difference
for me physically as well i mean i was
you know playing uh playing a game 40
plus hours a week
and sitting in a chair would lead to
positive
physical health either yeah you weren't
super ripped huh
no definitely not man
well jacob man i want to number one just
thank you for reaching out
um i appreciate all the emails and cards
and letters even the positive ones the
negative ones i love them but more
importantly i want you
to pat yourself on the back man i want
to thank you so much for reaching out
and letting me know about your journey
letting me know that you've got a heart
for people who are stuck in this video
game thing and if you don't play video
games like me
it's easy to go what are you talking
about
this is like a controller it's up up
down down left right left right
you're like ba select start right this
isn't like what are you talking about is
addicting
and then i forget that i've got my own
challenges i've got my own addictions
i've got my own drama in my life
and so i want to thank you for having
the courage to just come on the show and
tell everybody there's a better way if
you were in love with somebody who's
addicted to video games stand your
ground
have an ultimatum and if you are playing
video games 30 hours a week 20 hours a
week 40 hours a week
there is a better life there are going
to be real people around
real tables that provide you real
vulnerability and real joy in real life
and you're worth making those changes so
man jacob i'm really grateful for you
brother